it's time for Comic Con 2014 and here
are the highlights of the coolest things
to do and see Friday in Hall H AMC
presents the walking dead producers in
cast from the hit show discussed the
fourth season and what to look forward
to in the fifth season debuting this
fall on AMC join the panelists for a Q&A
session and sneak preview of new clips
from the show Game of Thrones panel
producers and cast members including
Gwendoline Christie Nikolaj
coster-waldau and Kit Harington will be
there for a QA of the epic fantasy
television series george RR martin will
also be there to answer questions about
the book series Marvel television panel
jeph loeb marvel's head of television
will present exciting news in a must-see
panel that will take you behind the
scenes horns Daniel Radcliffe attends
comic-con for the first time joining him
is Salma Hayek and Juno Temple to debut
the horns movie trailer and chat about
the movie the musk of tusk with Kevin
Smith writer and director Kevin Smith
premieres the trailer to his newest
movie tusk in this awesome panel the
Will Eisner comic industry awards the
26th annual eisner awards which are the
Oscars of the comics industry honor
comics and creators in 13 categories who
will win a prestigious eisner award this
year Star Wars storyboards panel for the
first time Lucasfilm has opened his
archives to present the original story
boards of the Star Wars trilogy famous
director Joe Johnston will present
artwork that has never been published
and discussed the upcoming JJ Abrams
Star Wars movie Robot Chicken Seth Green
and writers of the hysterical animation
show discussed the emmy-winning series
and show a sneak peek at upcoming
episodes Bob's Burgers producers and
cast of the popular animated show will
entertain you with never-before-seen
footage followed by a Q&A panel
discussion and those were the highlights
for Comic Con 2014 on Friday
you